[Music]
it was incredible it was amazing this is
the movie I've been waiting for since it
got announced and a finally see it on
the screen it's something I
I couldn't believe until the movie was
over absolutely now one of my favorite
Disney movies I think the single IMAX
really added that extra effect and
seeing all the amazing visuals and added
cinematography was amazing IMAX made me
feel like I was inside that ballroom
watching that dance it was amazing and I
loved it it was incredible I mean just
having it so big and so in-your-face and
growing up with Beauty and the Beast
it's you know every little girl wanted
to be Belle seeing in IMAX top to bottom
it has a whole different experience than
seeing anywhere else to truly experience
this film you should watch it in IMAX
Josh Katz character arc was amazing and
Haman's Lefou was just perfect yeah it
was beautiful I honestly cried like four
times sounds I mean honestly biagas
villegas I'm gonna be singing that song
like next week Oh seeing it right now
like this from animation to real life I
was holding back tears like crazy when I
watch it again with my fiancee I'll
probably sing along with IMAX right in
the beginning of the opening scene I
took a look at my family and my daughter
and my girls and I just saw their eyes
wide open just being me ah and just
watching the whole entire movie and that
kind of feel it was just spectacular and
I wouldn't watch it any other way
you
[Music]
you